[Musica]
d
ma ora lo riprendo già chiaro e adesso
via fila di fronte via credenti come due
quadrati
abbiamo via bianchi marmi colorati
ora i piedi rilascio e decotti
l'apertura via ero 6 rilascio dei
bianchi 8 bello spettacolo ai tratti via
quelli che abbiamo appena sentito sono
delle grazie quelle che abbiamo appena
sentito sono delle comunicazioni radio
comunicazioni radio fra la formazione in
volo e il comandante a terra durante un
tipico volo di addestramento delle
frecce tricolori la seconda voce che
avete ascoltato era la mia mi chiamo
vietano farina e solo il comandante
delle frecce tricolori dal 2018
quanti di voi hanno assistito a un
esibizione delle frecce tricolori ma
direi in tanti quasi tutti che questo fa
piacere
pensate che da quasi 60 anni la
pattuglia acrobatica nazionale
ambasciatrice nel mondo dei valori
dell'aeronautica militare del comparto
difesa e del nostro sistema paese alla
nostra bellissima italia come attraverso
il volo acrobatico collettivo
ma vi siete mai chiesti come facciamo
mantenere la posizione di ciascun
velivolo all'interno della formazione
lo facciamo provo a spiegarlo con un
esempio
e immaginiamo di essere sulla nostra
autovettura di superare un'altra
macchina e mentre siamo in sorpasso
cerchiamo di mantenere la posizione la
distanza della macchina che ci precede e
cosa facciamo e allineiamo due
riferimenti magari i due specchietti
retrovisori delle due macchine e
utilizziamo all'acceleratore e l'inerzia
della macchina per mantenere la
posizione è un po quello che facciamo in
volo solo con qualche
qualche complessità in più proprio
perché lo facciamo a circa 600
chilometri orari
a poco meno di due metri l'uno
dall'altro e con altri nove velivoli
attorno a noi che cercano di fare lo
stesso lavoro
questo è una situazione estrema una
situazione e saremo una condizione che
nell'essere così estrema a implicita in
sé la capacità di poter o meglio la
capacità di prevedere e di anticipare
ogni possibile emergenza e noi
anticipiamo le emergenze attraverso un
metodo un metodo basato sulla conoscenza
conoscenza dello scenario in cui stiamo
curando conoscenza dei task individuali
e collettivi dell'intera formazione e
conoscenza di quelle che sono le nostre
prestazioni senza mai lasciare nulla al
caso neanche ciò che all'apparenza
potrebbe sembrare un dettaglio
partiamo quindi dalla valutazione dello
scenario dall'analisi dello scenario in
un'ottica a catalogare tutte le
possibili soluzioni tutte le possibile
casistiche il pane quotidiano
come diceva un arnold gasco un noto uomo
d'affari usa del novecento l'essenza una
delle grandi forze della leadership sta
nel fatto che un leader è capace di
riconoscere un problema prima che questo
diventi un'emergenza
nel nostro caso tutti i dieci piloti
della formazione sono leader quindi sono
responsabili della propria vita e della
vita altrui
quindi è nulla può essere lasciato al
caso nascono così le checklist emergenze
check list che abbiamo sviluppato negli
anni e in ogni condizione
abbiamo scelto abbiamo
visto qual è la soluzione più adatta da
mettere in atto
a seconda della situazione che ci si
pone davanti
ovviamente una check list in se stessa
se sarebbe anche se pur corpose seppur
punti puntuale sarebbe vana se non ci
fosse dietro una conoscenza una
conoscenza di tutto ciò che ognuno di
noi deve fare non ci fosse un
addestramento negli anni nei 60 anni di
storia delle frecce tricolori il
pubblico così come voi hanno ammirato
più volte e ammirano l'esibizione delle
frecce a milano le figure acrobatiche
ammirano il tricolore steso in aria
però dietro tutto questo c'è una
tradizione la storia di 60 anni in cui
abbiamo creato abbiamo informato il
nostro programma di addestramento per
l'addestramento continuo
sono passato in prima persona un
addestramento che ci porta pian piano ad
ampliare quella che la nostra area di
performance
ognuno di noi comincia un neo assegnato
al gruppo delle frecce tricolori
comincia il proprio volo ovviamente non
si comincia direttamente a volare nella
formazione dei dieci velivoli sarebbe
impossibile ed impensabile
si parte dal singolo velivolo si
aggiunge poi un velivolo e si ricomincia
a volare informazione in coppia pian
piano vengono aggiunti altri velivoli
quindi le due sezioni delle frecce
tricolori che si incrociano è fan di
segnano in aria le figure del nostro
programma acrobatico e poi insieme alle
due sezioni viene aggiunto il solista
per completare così la il volo corale di
dieci velivoli della pattuglia
acrobatica nazionale è una un
addestramento continuo graduale che non
che non fa solo chi ne ha segnato
all'interno del gruppo delle frecce
tricolori ma anche chi è all'interno
delle frecce tricolori proprio perché
nella permanenza da gregario di circa 5
6 anni
tendiamo a far cambiare posizione questo
perché per evitare uno dei rischi più
comuni ossia al overconfidence la avere
eccessiva fiducia in se stessi questo è
un rischio che non possiamo permetterci
abbiamo realizzato quindi le prime due i
primi due punti quello del degli scenari
quello dell'addestramento e quindi della
valutazione
del dei propri tusk adesso andiamo ad
analizzare quale come andiamo a valutare
quelle che sono le nostre performance
delle frecce tricolori lo facciamo in
due momenti ben precisi
un primo momento che possiamo definire
live a caldo in cui il comandante a
terra da indicazioni dirette mentre la
pattuglia in volo da indicazioni dirette
ai dieci piloti della formazione dice
quali correzioni applicare per fare in
modo che il volo sia da un punto di
vista spettacolare il più bello
possibile sia condotto in sicurezza
e un po quello che abbiamo ascoltato
nelle comunicazioni radio all'inizio di
questo mio speech
il secondo momento è quello di me
briefing e invece che possiamo definire
a freddo in cui il comandante va un po
più nel dettaglio di quello che è il
volo di ogni singolo pilota e ogni
singolo pilota la possibilità di
passatemi il termine scendere dal dal
proprio velivolo di estraniarsi dal
copit e vedere la propria prestazione da
una posizione da una prospettiva diversa
che è quella del pubblico attraverso la
visione di un filmato tutto questo
perché per un continuo miglioramento
frecce tricolori non significa quindi un
talento innato o una propensione al
rischio la velocità l'essenza del nostro
lavoro sta nel creare ogni giorno
qualcosa di straordinario partendo da
fondamentale ordinari imprescindibili
perché senza una valutazione dello
scenario senza un addestramento continuo
e puntuale e senza soprattutto un
analisi di quelle che sono le nostre
prestazioni
le nostre performance non saremmo mai la
pattuglia acrobatica nazionale perché in
sintesi le emergenze sono parte di noi è
solo la conoscenza può portarci a
guardare con serenità a quel tricolore
che disegniamo nel cielo grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]